is this real information or
disinformation that's actually been a
role that goes Way Beyond AI who are
they really upset about uh they're upset
about that Elon Musk guy who by the way
was not invited to the world economic
Forum we're good at saying was this
automatically generated or not and I
think that where saying is this real
information or disinformation that's
actually been a role that goes Way
Beyond Ai and that's a role that
traditionally the media has stepped up
to play and I think that's the right
place for a lot of these questions
around uh this to be centered with the
support of technologists to help us help
you better tell those those stories and
and differentiate truth from
fiction I'm going to let both of you
jump in I just wanted to add however not
All Tech seos admit that they're not
good at every single thing so so I I
thank you for that at least one Tech CEO
hasn't been invited here um who who who
likes to think he's very good at media
as well he's just one of the I hate
those asexual we didn't invite him
because he's a little different from us
yeah the one guy they're talking about
Elon Musk obviously the one guy who has
opened up Twitter so more of us can
share ideas so we can debunk things in
real time so that Community notes their
factchecking apparatus can call out the
from our politicians and from
people like them and that's what they
hate the most so they didn't even invite
him
there